Daisy I think you're starting to film a
movie on Monday if I'm not mistaken uh
which is why I am believing Sundance so
what would you like to tell about this
project because I know it's very
personal to you
um the movie uh follows a family a woman
who is um at home
with a baby
um pushed slightly Beyond her limits and
her husband who is chaperoning their
daughter into a film set
um and who falls in love with the actors
playing the mother and it's a fantasy
versus reality and what things mean and
different perspectives and what they
lend to
um how we view characters and also what
the audience's biases May inform when
they're projecting onto the characters
so it's a lot of um things but my
husband Tom wrote it
um it's excellent and we have an amazing
uh cast and crew and honestly from
working on this like
it's just like the power of what people
can do together if everyone is like this
is what we're doing we're holding hands
we're like
you know we have limited time we have
limited budget this is what we have to
do and we get to be part of amazing
things are you the mom or are you the
I'm the Mom hey it's called Magpie yeah
I was just going to ask you just to
confirm the title